[Music]
you as a developer or DevOps manager are
telling me that security is a burden
security is the guys that always say
stop know what I want for you is a world
where security is under the covers and
transparent and it's not your problem
trust me forget it in a zero trust admin
world you don't have to trust the admin
the admin doesn't have access to your
data the admin can do their jobs set up
the system run the system maintain it
but without ever actually having access
to your data
in the objective architecture that we
all need to move towards every element
of the system is assured it can all be
tied into a chain of trust that's rooted
in hardware the way the chain of trust
gets built is what is very well known in
the security industry called measure and
verify every software component that
starts on the platform starting with the
firmware usually gets measured and
verified and that software component in
turn measures and launches the next
component in the chain firmware measures
the bias and verifies that buyers then
measures the operating system the
operating system measures and launches
that container runtime so the docker
system has some built in integrity
controls already but if you tie the
docker engine into a hardware rooted
chain of trust you can be sure that the
system that guarantees your integrity
within docker hasn't itself been
compromised and so you get a much more
robust overall picture of integrity this
can of course include both simple
integrity of the platform and the
containers that run on it as well as the
ability to encrypt container images to
be certain of not just integrity but
privacy as well
and all of the scales seamlessly because
you've enabled the orchestration system
to be run in a method that allows your
security to be transparent you build the
trust into the way for example
kubernetes clusters are deployed and
created you've assured that when a new
worker node is added to your cluster it
can't be added unless it's integrity is
already tested but that happens under
the covers unseen to you and assured by
the underlying platform so the scaling
is unlimited and frictionless
you
[Music]